what we're going to do in this video is
think about under which conditions does
the sampling distribution of the sample
proportions in which situations does it
look roughly normal and under which
situations does it look skewed
right so it doesn't look something like
this and under which situations does it
skewed look skewed left maybe something
like that
and the conditions that we're going to
talk about and this is a rough rule of
thumb that if we take our sample size
and we multiply it by the population
proportion that we care about and that
is greater than or equal to 10
and
and if we take the sample size and we
multiply it times 1 minus the population
proportion and that also is greater than
or equal to 10. if both of these are
true the rule of thumb tells us that
this is going to be approximately normal
in shape the sampling distribution of
the sample proportions so with that
in our minds let's do some examples here
so this first example says
emiliana runs a restaurant that receives
a shipment of 50 tangerines every day
according to the supplier approximately
12 percent of the population of these
tangerines is overripe
suppose that emiliana calculates the
daily proportion of over-ripe tangerines
in her sample of 50.
we can assume the supplier's claim is
true and that the tangerines each day
represent a random sample
what will be the shape of the sampling
distribution
distribution of the daily proportions of
over-ripe tangerines pause this video
think about what we just talked about
and see if you can answer this
all right so right over here we're
getting daily samples of 50 tangerines
so for this particular example our n
is equal to 50
and our population proportion the
proportion that is overripe is 12
percent so p is
0.12
so if we take n times p what do we get
and p is equal to 50 times 0.12
well 100 times this would be 12 so 50
times this is going to be equal to 6 and
this is less than or equal to 10.
so this immediately violates this first
condition and so we know that we're not
going to be dealing with a normal
distribution and so the question is how
is it going to be skewed
and the key realization is remember the
mean of the sample proportions of the
sampling distribution of the sample of
the sample proportions or the mean of
the sampling distribution of the daily
proportions that that's going to be the
same thing as our population proportion
so the mean is going to be 12 percent so
if i were to draw it let me see if i
were to draw it right over here where
this is 50 percent
and this is 100 percent our mean is
going to be right over here at 12
percent and so you're going to have it
really high over there and then it's
going to be skewed to the right you're
going to have a big long tail so this is
going to be skewed to the right
let's do another example
so here we're told according to a
nielsen survey radio reaches 88
of children each week
suppose we took weekly random samples of
n equals 125 children from this
population and computed the proportion
of children in each sample whom radio
reaches
what will be the shape of the sampling
distribution of the proportions of
children the radio reaches once again
pause this video and see if you can
figure it out
all right well let's just figure out
what n and p are our sample size here n
is equal to 125 and our population
proportion that of the proportion that
of children that are reached each week
by radio is 88
so p is
0.88 so now let's calculate np
so n is 125
times p is 0.88 and is this going to be
greater than or equal to 10 well we
don't even have to calculate this
exactly this is almost 90 of 125 this is
actually going to be over 100 so it for
sure is going to be greater than 10 so
we meet this first condition but what
about the second condition we could take
n 125
times 1 minus b so this is times 0.12
so this is 12
of 125.
well even 10 percent of 125 would be
12.5 so 12
is for sure going to be greater than
that so this 2 is going to be greater
than 10. i didn't even have to calculate
it i could just estimate it and so we
meet that second condition so even
though our population proportion is
quite high it's quite close to one here
because our
because our sample size is so large it
still will be roughly normal and one way
to get the intuition for that is
so
this is
a proportion of zero let's say this is
fifty percent and this is a hundred
percent so our mean right over here is
going to be at zero point eight eight
for our sampling distribution of the
sample proportions if we had a low
sample size then our standard deviation
would be quite large and so then you
would end up with a left skewed
distribution but we saw before the
higher your sample size the smaller your
standard deviation for the sampling
distribution and so what that does is it
tightens up
it tightens up the standard deviation
and so it's going to look more normal
it's going to look closer it's going to
look closer to being normal
so we'll say approximately normal
because it met our conditions for this
rule of thumb is it going to be
perfectly normal no in fact if we didn't
have this rule of thumb to kind of draw
the line some might even argue that well
we still have a longer tail to the left
than we do to the right maybe it's good
to the left but using this threshold
using this rule of thumb which is the
standard in statistics this would be
viewed as approximately normal